Lynne is with us to start off this hour
in Charlottesville hey Lynn how are you
I'm good how are you doing better than I
deserve I think you taking my call
I've got all sorts of questions but the
one I called about was my husband and I
are just getting started
which means I'm just getting started
getting serious about a budget and one
discussion we had over the weekend was
the idea of we have at least well two
that I'm really aware of yet that are
interest-free what is the medical debt
and one of the court costs his
contention is there's no real reason to
pay those off in a big hurry because
they're they're interest-free my
contention is getting out of debt is
worth getting out of debt what can I
tell him I mean is it is that a good
thing just paid a little bit that we
take because we pay very little bit
towards it so I'm not quite sure what to
do what what reasoning to give him or
amazing how long have you guys been
married
ah six years what's your household
income about thirty four thousand okay
and so here's the thing in business
here's what I was telling in business
there's a process that we use called
best practices and that means if I want
to do a marketing campaign I try to find
another business has done a marketing
campaign like that it was successful and
I copy them that's what best practices
means I find someone who's got best
practices and I emulate or copy those
best practices if I want to have a great
marriage I don't talk - somebody's been
divorced 62 times I hope somebody's been
married 62 years mm-hmm and let them get
advice from that sweet old lady to tell
me how to be married right right if I
want to have great kids I don't talk to
someone who raised three kids
in jail right right bang bet that's best
practices I talk to them I raised three
stellar citizens who ended up being
neurosurgeons or whatever right right
that's what I want to talk to and so
what you and your husband need is best
practices for handling money because
your practices that you currently have
suck yes we'll be here old and so I
don't give a crap okay my point is I'm
trying to in a very nice way to say his
opinion about money doesn't matter
because his results suck that's why
that's what I'm trying to say but I'm
trying to say it in a very nice way you
follow me I mean he's like a fat guy
sitting telling you how to get out of
debt I tell you how to lose weight man
that's silly and so time for Bubba to
wake up say I gotta try something new
now I'm being I'm being kind of funny
and sarcastic I wouldn't want you to be
disrespectful to your husband that's not
what I'm saying it's not going to get
you anywhere
asabi since he agrees with so much of
what you say yeah I'm part but he agrees
about enough of it except the part that
he wants to change and he's the guy
sitting there broke and so this is
what's known as a proven plan 10 million
people have used this plan to get out of
that he doesn't need to come along
making $34,000 a year and in debt and
fix this plan and somehow you need to
say that to him very nicely to where we
don't I'm not trying to get you pick a
fight I'm going to no but but what I am
saying is - honey you know listen to
them gaint man Dave Ramsey's not real
smart he know anything anything but this
he knows this all he does know and he's
the best at this and millions of people
have done this let's try it his way
because we've tried it your way and
that's how we got where yeah yeah he is
his contention is I don't give a crap
what his contention is he says yeah I
guess for why get out of debt if you
only have these tiny little payments why
not borrow 20 million dollars then if
you got no interest well
that's about as logical because you know
the point is is that we're not winning
with money and we need to try something
different
mm-hmm let's try this list your debts
regardless of interest rate smallest to
largest pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one and attack
the little one regardless of interest so
I don't care that they're interest-free
you're not getting rich
keeping these interest-free debts all
right it's not working for you yeah so
it's time to change it's like if you
went to the Y for six weeks and you're
on a workout program and you gained
weight you would not go unless your
purpose was to gain weight you're trying
to build up muscle but I mean if you
went there to lose weight and you gained
weight then you would say this plan is
not working I need a different plan
mm-hmm and that's what we're doing here
so I'm not going to argue with this and
I don't really want you to argue with it
it's there is no logic that says keep
debt around there's not any because the
only way that that logic works is if you
take away risk and you can't take away
risk because risk is part of the program
so it's freaking core cost it's a
medical bill pay them off they're not
even that big pay them off list your
debts smallest to largest pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
one and attack the little one with the
Vengeance and it's not because Dave
Ramsey cares if you do what Dave Ramsey
says that's not the point the point is
this works it's a proven best practice
that millions that's without an
exaggeration millions and millions of
people have done this so you guys don't
need to sit in Charlottesville and
reinvent it you don't need to there's no
point in it just go do what's working
and that's how I would go about
convincing anyone to do this and if you
hate my way you can go back in debt
after you get out it's not a problem
it's not really not does it take long at
all
you know why most people don't win they
don't bother you have to bother it to be
intentional never again as American
Express going to call my house and ask
my wife why she would stay with a man
that won't pay his bills